vacances à l'étranger maintenant avec
une destination particulièrement voc
cette année c'est berlin la ville est
passé en troisième position derrière
londres et paris comme destination
touristique en europe
mais la spécificité avec berlin c'est
que cette ville peut se visiter plus
facilement et plus agréablement à vélo
correspondance jérôme baugnies brice
boire c'est d'une ancienne brasserie de
l'est de berlin que partent les
cyclotouristes sans doute la meilleure
façon de découvrir la ville dotée de 750
km de pistes cyclables
c'est vrai que la ville est assez plate
ou pour ça ça va si les gens sont pas
très sportif ils s'en sortent quand même
parce qu'ils n'ont pas vraiment de
colima montée like j'aime cette ville où
est la partie ouest est un peu trop
américaine à mon goût mais j'aime l'est
on peut même aller où les voitures sont
interdites
ben ali tout le monde roule à vélo ici
vous avez vu tout le monde marche tout
fait de fait les trois quarts des
berlinois empruntent ces pistes
cyclables qu'ils sont parfois du mal à
faire respecter
pour les visiteurs plus mous du genou il
y a aussi le vélo taxi et pour les
solitaires les bicyclettes très design
des chemins de fer allemands un coup de
téléphone pour donner son numéro de
carte de crédit
moyennant quoi on obtient le code qui
permet de déverrouiller l'antivol c'est
le temps d'utilisation du vélo qui est
facturé jusqu'au moment où on le laisse
n'importe où rck a menacé est prêt pour
le prochain utilisateur
mille façons de visiter la capitale
allemande avec même cet engin à cette
place il ya son petit succès
sauver le programme est génial ce n'est
pas seulement écologique mais surtout
c'est très convivial
rien d'étonnant à ce que le nombre de
touristes visitant berlin est augmenté
de 20 % l'année dernière la ville est à
la mode surtout chez les jeunes